what is a perfect day in the life of
Daniel negrono look like when you're
like on a day when you have to play a
big game big tournament game and so on
so like what what time do you wake up
what do you eat for breakfast so my life
is twofold like one when I'm playing
hardcore and one when I'm not and they
look very different right so I'll give
you a quick glimpse of like when I'm not
up at 10
you know breakfast in the gym at noon
you know the post-workout uh meal coffee
uh walk like you know I try to get
that's what I do for cardio you know
it's very like home-bodied I don't leave
the house it's very like boring and
mundane right long distance walk so like
what do you do when you're walking
you're thinking about stuff well no
honestly I just walk on the treadmill I
try to get 15 000 steps a day and I just
walk for basically like an hour while I
watch a show or I'm on the computer or
something like that you know I'm on the
treadmill why walking not running
well I mean I think walking I mean I do
a little bit of running but hardly any I
don't enjoy it like I just like walking
and frankly for fat loss when it's
usually what I'm doing after big poker
tournaments is getting back in shape
that walking's ideal for it right so so
essentially it's like the Tail tool
during the World Series of Poker
all my sort of structured life thrown
out the window there's no walking
there's very little walking there's very
little working out there's very little
anything I go into the World Series
you know like this year I went in around
157 and I expected to gain about 10
pounds during the World Series not good
pounds wasn't muscle but that's about
what I did 165 and then I spent the next
month trying to you know lose it but
during the World Series when I'm playing
the most important thing without
question that I have to focus on and
this is why I stopped focusing on
working on all this stuff is sleep if
I'm not rested I'm useless if I only get
five six hours and I have to go back the
next day and play 14 hours the chances
of me being at my best very very slim so
sleep is a priority what's the perfect
amount of sleep for you on those days
eight so eight hours is my go-to every
night during the World Series of Poker
it's just not possible because of the
way that it's structured sometimes the
tournaments end at 2 15 a.m I get home
about three o'clock
takes me to 30 minutes 40 minutes to get
to sleep so let's say I'm in bed by four
well the tournament said you know two so
I have to get up and whatever so it's
very difficult to get exactly eight a
lot of the time you know and also get
back there in time is there any hacks to
uh quiet the mind
because you're going on a pretty intense
roller coaster mentally when you're
playing
was is there any tricks to getting to
sleep given uh I've been very lucky like
I'm blessed I don't know if it's because
of diet or what but I've always been a
very good sleeper you just shut off I
get to sleep and I sleep like a baby you
know and I also nap really well like
during the World Series sometimes what
will happen is let's say I get knocked
out of one event at 4 pm and there's
another one that I can jump in instead
of jumping right into it I'll go into
like a private room and take 45 minute
nap and you know and give me enough
energy to to continue and sort of reset
my mind yeah and it solves a lot of
problems with the nap too it does yeah
yeah I feel like the nap is is a magical
trick in life
what else diet wise what do you uh your
your mind is going
you know uh pretty intensely all day
yeah so during like like I said when I'm
not playing I'm super regimented you
know I have I literally measure
everything you know I count calories I
count macros I follow it to a t pretty
balanced diet or any I'm a vegan vegan
so it's you know a vegan diet like a
balance in terms of carbs yeah yeah no I
mean I eat a healthy amount I'm doing
probably 150 grams of protein and uh
like 60 grams of fat 50 and then about
and try to measure it all out I do yeah
basically I created a meal plan so what
I did for myself is because I'm really
anal and nerd I made a spreadsheet with
like a day's food and I have six
different ones so I just follow it like
I don't it actually makes my life so
much easier when I don't have to think
about what I'm gonna eat for lunch or
what I need for dinner I already know
what I'm gonna eat I already wrote it
down and it doesn't get boring because
I'm switching it up every day you know
every six days and again occasionally
I'll you know splurge and do something
different during the World Series of
Poker I eat whatever the [ __ ] I want to
eat yeah like it's at 2 A.M I don't
crave like a broccoli carrot salad like
I want chocolate candy and chips so I'll
just do it so you listen to the Cravings
yeah I realized like it's surprising
because like you're so regimented
outside of that it's really difficult
like I've done it before where I played
the World Series of Poker and I made it
a point to work out every day but what
that did was it sacrificed sleep yeah so
then I found like at 1am I would be more
tired you know because I've spending
more energy than I would otherwise so I
essentially like look at the World
Series it's six seven weeks where my
body's just gonna take a beating not
like a UFC fighter but like a different
kind of beating and that's okay because
I have so much confidence that within
six weeks of just like eating right and
working out I can get back to where I
was it was just hilarious to me that
you'd be eating chocolate but eating
chocolate in bed as you're trying to get
to sleep is this like literally a bag of
like chips or chocolate yeah like on my
way home and before bed you know just
whatever this is what the professional
athlete does at the uh it's the highest
most difficult event of his career okay
so
um what else is there in terms of mental
preparation and uh focus and meditation
those kinds of things leading up to the
games
is there anything you like to like any
rituals you like to follow
so yeah I have dabbled in the past with
like meditation and different things
like that and I know that there's health
benefits to it and I and I understand
that a lot of people get a lot from it
and I've done it for good amount of time
like long periods of time I found that
for me I think it was predominantly
Placebo like it it really wasn't doing
anything yeah for me that I felt like it
was it felt like I was doing something
but I really I didn't see the any
specific results from it so
um so I don't really do that too much
one thing that I will do
for me is bleeding up is there so much
footage now that I'll make it a point to
like watch my opponents and then with
like my phone I'll take notes and I'll
keep track of different things that I'm
seeing and that sort of and then what
I'll do is I'll formulate a game plan
like I'm playing the poker Masters
coming up in about a week and I'll look
to see the Tendencies what my opponents
are doing and then I'll come up with
like some some things that I'm gonna do
some tricks of the trade if you will not
Game Theory optimal stuff stuff that I
think oh they're making a mistake here
that I can exploit and then I look to do
that in different ways and always look
to you know throw curveballs
how hard is that that process uh do you
enjoy it or is it like really hard work
to analyze the players to try to
understand what are the different holes
what are the different mistakes what are
the strengths to avoid and that kind of
stuff
I think the only thing that makes it
harder is when you're young right you're
in your 20s and you're trying to make
your nest egg you're like you're trying
to make your retirement money you're
hungry right you're like Clubber Lang
and you know the gym you're hungry
whereas you know Rocky's in there taking
pictures and smiling and doing
commercials stuff like that so I am 47
I'm financially okay I don't need to win
I don't need to compete at the highest
levels so I think it was a boxer I don't
remember which one when asked this he
was asked the question um you know how
do you get up in the morning you know
still and and do those morning runs and
he says you know what I'll be honest
with you it's a lot more difficult doing
the 4am run in silk pajamas right it
just is right but I've always been
self-motivated and I've always found a
way so it's harder in the sense of like
it's not a need I can still get by
without it but so in that regard it does
feel like a little bit of work we're
like oh my God that's a lot of footage I
got to get through and I don't know that
I have the timer I don't know that I
want to spend
10 hours of my day doing that when I
could be doing other things I mean what
do you still love about poker when you
said when you enter like the times you
catch yourself just uh
being able to sort of take in the awe of
it
what aspects do you love I think that
like for me I've always been really
competitive but I was never going to be
a professional athlete a professional
snooker player I wasn't good enough at
any of that stuff I didn't have the body
type whatever
um but poker it sort of levels a playing
field right you're six five to forty big
deal you know we're not we're not
fighting here we're we're fighting a
different type of War so the competitive
aspect I also have always been fueled
throughout my career by by doubters so
this is probably unhealthy but every
time people say like you're done you're
washed up you can't win anymore it just
makes me want to prove them wrong yeah
right so I have a little bit of that in
me which again you reading the comments
and all these kind of like I've been
told many times throughout my career for
the last 15 that I'm done I can't
compete anymore and uh and I and I enjoy
you know proven them wrong